[JET BLAST]
LYLA FUJIWARA: At
Google I/O 2017,
we announced the
Lifecycle Library.
The Lifecycle Library is a
set of libraries and guidance
for avoiding memory leaks
and solving common Android
lifecycle challenges.
Now the Lifecycle
Library has hit 2.0.
It's part of Jetpack.
And it includes new
integrations with data binding.
This is a tour of the Lifecycle
Library's ViewModel class.
A ViewModel holds
your app's UI data
while surviving
configuration changes.
Here's why that's
actually useful.
Rotating your phone is
considered a configuration
change.
Configuration changes
cause your whole activity
to get torn down
and then recreated.
If you don't properly
save and restore data
from the destroyed activity,
you may lose that data
and end up with weird
UI bugs or even crashes.
So enter the ViewModel,
which, of course,
survives configuration changes.
Instead of storing all of
your UI data in your activity,
put it in the ViewModel instead.
Now, this helps with
configuration changes,
but it's also just general
good software design.
One common pitfall when
developing for Android
is putting a lot of
variables, logic, and data
into your activities
and fragments.
This creates a large,
unmaintainable mess of a class
and violates the single
responsibility principle.
You can use ViewModels to easily
divide out that responsibility.
The ViewModels will be
responsible for holding
all of the data that you're
going to show in your UI.
And then the activity
is only responsible
for knowing how to draw
that data to the screen
and receiving user interactions,
but not for processing them.
If your app loads
and stores data,
I suggest making a
repository class,
as described in the "Guide
to App Architecture."
Make sure your ViewModel
doesn't become bloated
with too many responsibilities.
To avoid this, you can
create a presenter class
or implement a more fully
fledged clean architecture.
OK, so to make a
ViewModel, you'll
end up extending
the ViewModel class.
And then you put your
UI-related instance variables
that were previously in your
activity into your ViewModel.
Then in your
activity's onCreate,
you get the ViewModel from
a framework utility class
called ViewModel Provider.
Notice the ViewModel Provider
takes an activity instance.
This is the
mechanism that allows
you to rotate the device, get
a technically new activity
instance, but always ensure that
activity instance is associated
with the same ViewModel.
With the ViewModel
instance, you can
use Getters and
Setters to access
UI data from your activity.
If you want to modify the
default constructor, which
currently takes
no parameters, you
can use a ViewModel Factory to
create a custom constructor.
Now, this is the simplest
use case of a ViewModel.
But the ViewModel class is
also designed to work well
with LiveData and data binding.
Using all of these together,
you can create a reactive UI,
which is just a fancy way of
saying a UI that automatically
updates whenever the
underlying data changes.
This assumes all of your
data in your ViewModel
that you plan to show on
screen is wrapped in LiveData.
You then should set up
data binding as normal.
Here's an example
XML with the data
binding layout tag
and the variable tag
for your ViewModel.
Then in your
activity or fragment,
you associate the variables used
in the XML with the binding.
Here's an example
with an activity.
There's one new line of
code, setLifecycleOwner.
This allows the binding to
observe your LiveData objects
in the ViewModel.
And it's essentially
the magic that
lets the binding update
whenever the LiveData updates
and the ViewModel's onscreen.
You can now directly
reference LiveData fields
from your ViewModel in your XML.
If you combine this
with binding adapters,
you can move much
of the boilerplate
logic out of your activity.
Note that this became
available at Android Studio 3.1
and higher, so make sure
you're on the correct version.
To learn more, check out
the Introduction to LiveData
in the docs.
OK, I'm going to finish off
with a few best practices.
First tip, you should never
pass contexts into ViewModels.
This means no passing in
fragments, activities,
or views.
As you saw earlier,
ViewModels can
outlive your specific activity
and fragment lifecycles.
Let's say that you store an
activity in your ViewModel.
When you rotate the screen,
that activity is destroyed.
You now have a ViewModel
holding a reference
to a destroyed activity.
And this is a memory leak.
So if you find yourself needing
application contexts, which
outlive ViewModel lifecycles,
use the Android ViewModel
subclass instead.
This includes a reference to
the application for you to use.
OK, second tip.
ViewModels are meant
to be used in addition
to onSaveInstanceState.
ViewModels do not
survive process shutdown
due to resource restrictions.
But onSaveInstance bundles do.
ViewModels are great for
storing huge amounts of data.
onSaveInstanceState
bundles, not so much.
Use ViewModels to store as
much UI data as possible
so that that data doesn't need
to be reloaded or regenerated
during a configuration change.
onSaveInstanceState,
on the other hand,
should store the
smallest amount of data
needed to restore the UI state
if the process is shut down
by the framework.
So for example, you might
store all of the user's data
within the ViewModel but just
store the user's database ID
in onSaveInstanceState.
Hopefully this has inspired you
to try out the new ViewModel
class in your apps
either by itself
or with the other
architecture components.
To learn more about
using ViewModels or any
of the information
that I just mentioned,
check out the
documentation below.
[JET BLAST]